bonsoir météo gm merci merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur un écran ce dans ce
clip on a vu voilà plein de deux pays
différents tout cas alors leur presse
réagir mais pas l'italie que tu ton chez
vous bonsoir je veux dire qu'un l'italie
surtout la presse de gauche a titré les
sur cette agression sur cette action de
la police en soulignant le caractère
raciste pour le reste honnêtement la
presse italienne n'a pas donné trop de
commandes hier d'importance à cet
événement plutôt à la manifestation ils
ont parlé plus tôt de la manifestation
contre l'article 24 de la loi sur la
sécurité mais disons que cet épisode a
été surtout stigmatisé par la presse de
gauche avant justement y at il une forme
pas d'amalgamé une confusion entre
toutes ces violences policières
présumées ou non l'article 24 cette
affaire est clair est-ce qu'un mélange
qui se fait justement selon vous dans
les médias étrangers
oui parce que déjà on ne comprend pas
exactement la réalité française de
l'autre côté on lit l'actualité
française avec des lunettes qui sont
celles de son propre pays
donc en ce qui concerne les médias
américains je suis pas un expert mais
les titres que je pu lire
c'était été un peu comme une façon pour
dire attention il ya effectivement eu un
phénomène blake l'afp m qui va éclater
en france aussi
or les deux situations sont complètement
différent dans l'essence que le black
light bearer s'installent sur des années
des décennies de comment dire les
tensions raciales aux états unis là où
il y avait
corps il ya quelques années dans
certains états des lois qui était
effectivement un style l'apartheid on
peut dire quand ça en france ce n'est
pas du tout le cas
et d'ailleurs il n'ya pas comment dire
des autorités et des administrations
locales qui prône pour certaines
comédies comportement raciste ou
discriminatoire vis-à-vis d'une partie
de la population
donc je pense que sur tous les médias
américains ont fait un peu une bonne
guerre entre guillemets parce que on
avait accusé aussi justement là les
états unis d'avoir de toute façon des
problèmes avec la violence qui sont en
tout cas assez clair par exemple aussi
la diffusion des armes à feu qui est
légal aux états unis qui est considéré
quelque chose d'incompréhensible de
cette côté de l'océan
vous parlez du mouvement blake les
demandeurs justement à bruxelles le soir
évoque une affaire john floyd à la
française ce qu'on peut faire ce
parallèle clairement selon vous
décidément non non vous ceux qui le font
sont enterrés à gt de l'huile sur le feu
ils ont des intérêts politiques sans
doute parce qu'on a vu l'extrême gauche
et une partie de la gauche française et
aussi d'autres pays européenne investir
7 cet espace pour
condamné toute forme de d'autorité non
seulement d' autoritarisme qui serait
peut être compréhensible à 10 ans une
condamnation de l'autoritarisme mais
toute forme d'autorité et puis ce qui
concerne cet événement je pense que il
manque qu'il nous manque beaucoup
d'éléments aussi pour considérer la
situation bien sûr cette agression a été
très violente est absolument à condamner
mais certains observateurs ont quand
même rappeler que on n'a pas vu toute la
scène on n'a pas eu toutes les
informations
comme d'ailleurs pour d'autres faits qui
sont un peu un similaire à celui ci
alors la presse dit volontiers pays des
droits de l'homme quand elle évoque la
france cela égratine peut-être plus
encore davantage l'image du président au
micro l étranger je pense qu'à
l'étranger on considère la france comme
un pays qui pourrait jouir disons de
céder ses libertés à 100% et des ces
luttes qui qui qui qui sont à la base de
son histoire au moins depuis 300 ans
mais un peu pas dire plus mais
on le fait pas parce que il ya
effectivement cette verticalité du
pouvoir qui s'est accentuée quand on a
abandonné le cette teneur et canton à
synchroniser les élections législatives
avec c'est la présidentielle de la même
année
donc on voit que d'un côté on pourrait
imaginer que le président français du
moment donc pas seulement emmanuel
macron est tout puissant mais en réalité
il est aussi comment dire un
paratonnerre parce qu' il ne peut pas
conduire donner la responsabilité a
aussi à d'autres institutions de décider
ou mieux ou pour mieux dire et pourrait
le faire mais ne le fait pas parce que
c'est très pratique après d'avoir un
parlement qui vote selon les ordres du
gouvernement
en tout cas emmanuel macron avait déjà
accusé ya pas si longtemps la presse
anglo saxonne de son traitement sur la
question notamment de de l'islam c'est
un nouveau grand malentendu entre
emmanuel macron et la presse notamment
anglo saxonnes
ça dépend parce que parfois on voit que
la presse anglo saxonne donne beaucoup
d'espacé à emmanuel macron mais il faut
dire aussi que la presse anglo saxonne
et et un général encore une fois
la presse surtout de tendance de gauche
al attiyah comment dire à une
prédisposition pour considérer tout de
suite tout ce qui est mesure d'autorité
pour résoudre une série des problèmes
qu'en france on s'appelle par exemple
terrorisme islamiste djihadisme et
d'autres qu'on dirait crise sociale
il les considère tout de suite comme un
acte raciste
or moins honnêtement j'ai entendu aussi
des observateurs qui effectivement a
remarqué que ces policiers qui ont été
tout de suite arrêté est en tout cas ils
ont commencé à être jugé par la justice
justement mais ils n'ont pas eu droit au
même traitement que certains criminels
rond quand ils ont commis leur premier
crime en essence que on les a laissés
est comment dire en liberté on les a
laissés faire encore des dégâts alors
que c'est policiers et étaient à leur
premier la première infraction
je pense qu'il y a eu un peu une
légèreté qui a risqué de des données la
police la partie saine de la police en
pâture
à ceux qui voulaient instrumentaliser
son travail sans eau sans se rappeler
que la police risque beaucoup dans ce
pays parce qu'on se rappelle qu'il ya eu
deux terroristes qui sont même rentrés
chais des policiers ils les ont tués
devant leurs enfants
donc on peut pas dire que c'est tout
blanc ou tout noir mais comment dire il
faut toujours se rappeler que cette
façon de juger a priori et qui est
amplifié aussi par les réseaux sociaux
et que donc on perd un peu le sang froid
merci beaucoup ma théorie gisèle
berthier rédacteur en chef de putsch
médias d'avoir été avec nous